that's very difficult sometimes
sometimes in mice you know um
my senior years and a lot of work in
print I'm asked to go to colleges this
teach a class or speak before students
students of non-fiction writing and they
asked a lot of questions and how did you
do this and how did you do that and I
tell them but sometimes I think to
myself how are these people going to get
a job and while these people are very
interested in eager and and certainly
attentive to what I am saying in these
in these classroom sessions I wonder how
they ever going to do it because the the
life has changed in the year 2009 it's
none at all like it was in 1959 when I
started writing for magazines and I
started I kept continue I kept writing
for magazines for the 1960s into the 70s
that piece by Franklin Frank Sinatra was
published in 1966 and when I did that
piece Esquire was the publisher they
sent me out to California they put me in
a very fine hotel the Beverly Wilshire
hotel in Beverly Hills California I was
able to rent a car I was able to have an
expense account and take people to lunch
to dinner and I kept careful records of
course I always have that what I spend
because I'm to be reimbursed and I want
to be very accurate about it and there
was never even when I was was not
getting the cooperation that it was
expected I would because it was expected
I would get an interview but I never got
an interview but I still stayed out
there and talk to all these minor people
that I mentioned earlier and never did
the editor say oh listen you better come
home I actually volunteered when I was
taking the Beverly Wilshire of it was a
third or fourth day I was aware that
that maybe I should move to a cheaper
hotel find a place I was gonna spend a
lot of time out there it turns out I
spent about four weeks in Beverly Hills
just research and I'd asked the other if
he wanted me to look for a hotel room
that wouldn't be so expensive he said no
stay where you are now that wouldn't
happen now but a lot of things have
happened
that make life for young writers who
would like to do what I used to do but
it's so changed the technology I think
is how to Ronis effect it started with
the tape recorder that was number one
the worst thing ever happened to
nonfiction serious nonfiction writing
was the tape recorder what this did was
allow reporters or magazine writers to
use Q&A techniques the
question-and-answer question and answer
to take a tape recorder and then rather
not not much time at all to get a lot of
verbatim quotes from from well-known
people magazines prefer to have
well-known people and they put them on
the cover usually they're movie stars
they're well-known people in aspects of
political life and the tape recorder
allows a reporter to go to a home to a
hotel room for example an interview a
movie star and with a matter of about an
hour we'll get enough for an article and
and then go back and write it using a
lot of direct quotes some of these
quotes I said earlier aren't quotes that
I would want to use because it doesn't
necessarily mean what people have in
their heads it's rather what they're
coming out of their mouths of the
station extended sound bites is what
they're getting and also I think in the
process of having a tape recorder they
brought the whole format of the magazine
article indoors because the tape
recorder is done indoors most of the
pieces that I wrote and still would
write if I was able to do what I want to
do would be outdoors I go I travel with
people my technique is is hanging out
with people when I wrote about Sinatra I
didn't it was never indoors when I was
watching him in the studio I described
it when he was recording I watched him
taking walks in in in Las Vegas as he
went from casino to casino the scenes of
his gambling going to a prizefight in
Las Vegas they're their big scenes and
they were they were outdoors they were
very descriptive and
told the reader what it was like to be
there it wasn't this narrow question
answer question answer and the owners of
magazines the publisher or the editor or
the owner are very interested in
cost-cutting of course and the tape
recorder played right into that moreover
it would be to the advantage of the
publisher of a magazine to have things
directly unquote with tape recorder to
verify so though the lawyers would be
able to fight off any any challenge in
terms of misquotation
libel suits so that was another
contribution to the cost-cutting
emphasis that was brought by editors
upon the writing process what you have
now with exceptions some great like a
great mega length like the New Yorkers
exception but what you have now is
nothing of the kind of the art of the
magazine piece that I I and many others
of my generation used to practice we had
expense accounts either also that tape
recorder meant that you didn't have to
send people out to the other side of the
United States you could wait for the
movie star or the singing star the rock
star to come to New York
forming at Madison Square Garden staying
at the Pierre hotel or the Beverly
Wilshire hood of the The Plaza Hotel or
wherever this thing and you send
somebody over there with a tape recorder
and then and they over an hour so
they'll get a lot of quotes so the
magazine pieces is not a work of art
anymore